every now and again you might hear some
children outside of my window when I
film and here are three of them right
now
everyone say your name is your name Jose
these ones are very supportive they're
very loving they're very cool
there's a couple more of them I think
right yeah because the kids love for
real rejects so is there anything you
guys want to say to the few thousand
people that are watching you guys have a
channel oh you guys are you guys are
just chat promote yourselves you're
trying to take advantage of me
guys my name is Greg and my name is John
John and I today are two friends who
like the original movie The Exorcist so
we couldn't be more enthused when we
heard that Fox was doing the Exorcist
television show inspired by the classic
movie no other network is better than
Fox to bring us the Exorcist television
adaptation well you know I mean I've
always wanted to see The Exorcist but if
it took place in Miami he hit the
spacebar jet yeah sometimes God keeps
you a job and when that happens you have
to drop him and just start yeah hey
Casey how's your sister
she's gonna cast off last week she's a
lot of fun that was a lovely service I
want to talk sometime Victoria's always
hope I mean this family allergic to
light what do you want
just call him crying so that wasn't
weird
there's no meaner Shirley climbs up on
her cross and she wants some attention
my daughter
she's back from college it's just
different yeah
the way she talks where she looks at me
it's not depression
I know depression there are things going
on in the house in my house there are
voices inside the walls
I am NOT a crazy person I'm not saying
you're crazy
there is something inside my house it's
demon a demon it's trying to take my
daughter classic truthfully Michaels
what can you tell me about demonic
possession I had a dream you're in it
whoa school is awesome there was a child
that type who are mad
boom you didn't come here for advice you
gotta help the Azzurri
oh my girl be my parish
you're afraid yeah you should be too
that was probably no no
music okay maybe have a little intrigue
yeah actually really cool really bitchin
trailer that is a really action it
doesn't feel like you know Fox censored
down kind of trail like it feels
anything more like something like the
American Horror Story creators would
have done you know well and nowhere TV
is changing I feel like Hannah will
probably certainly open the door for
this for anything to you know to network
TV and pushing the boundaries of network
TV and it seems like if they get this
right that's what this is gonna be for
Fox totally it seems like there's
character interactions that I'm really
like actually interested in I don't know
the characters names
I don't know these actors are the two
priests you know when they when the cool
priest was like doing his thing and not
looking at the other golden yeah like a
cool way to redo the priest yeah yeah
it's a badass way to like me like this
is a badass priest right here yeah I
like the main guy Geena Davis that's a
boat yeah it would seem as though she
she looks at her face is a little stiff
a little artificial yeah a little bit
but I thought that was part of the
character okay maybe I thought she was
doing kind of like a UH jessica laying
kind of thing well that's yeah that's
exactly across my mind they've clearly
taken notes with this that could be
Cooke's there are flashes in that
trailer where I'm like Geena Davis looks
like she's laying down a performance
there are a couple of moments and it's
not just with her there are a couple
moments that pop up here and there were
I'm like this could cross over into
being a little more cheesy melodrama
like the thing with the crow and maybe
it's just rollin me and she's like
freaking out like a long time it's like
predictable to the whole bird the window
come on yeah it was all like great until
that like one moment where I was like is
this what's gonna be like when he gets
creepy and scary I felt like as I kept
going now as I was as I as shot really
well there was some truly creepy moments
in a trailer it looks like they're doing
more than just like extending
Exorcist movie out like I feel like
they're actually setting up characters
that I could watch you're gonna watch
these two priests it seems like they're
gonna really expand that and make that
probably part that it's probably his art
for the first season yeah and then
you're gonna have the story of the
family and the girls seems like they're
using TV for what it's worth and going
all these people are gonna get their own
yeah exactly
it doesn't seem like it's any caught up
and trying to sell some like thrills and
yeah for fun you know it seems like
they're gonna they're pretty confident
with the trailer we just saw like those
were scenes that were playing out for a
lot of it it wasn't just a [ __ ] ton of
quick flashes the whole time well
they've done something that's really
hard to do where it is it's exactly that
it's like there's some really freaky
imagery and some stuff that looks like
an exorcism movie in here but it does a
good job of making it seem like that's
not gonna be all the time yeah it feels
like this show is gonna like have time
to take its time yeah you know and
that's what looks nice about it it
doesn't feel like it has to always be
this like hyper stylized or really like
intense thing all the time feel like
there's gonna be moments of just good
dramatic scenes like they've almost
learned from The Walking Dead's mistake
on that because everyone's complain for
seasons on Ndebele those zombies anymore
and like I feel like this trailer kind
of helps them with that problem if
anyone's like losin of exorcisms like
you know it seems like they've really
addressed that well alright Fox looks
like I'm there check out your show you
want me over it it seems like they're
finally at least seriously had my dad
and it's shot really well yeah yeah it
looks hog rafi there's like creepy and
haunting like I love the tone of it
hides like this feels like a legit
creepy kind of time yeah you know it's
starting to look like HP over yapped on
HBO or Showtime HP HP oh-- home box
office well guys
yeah thanks for informing me about that
trailer I was pleasantly surprised about
pretty tree but if you're new to the
channel please subscribe today
it'll be worth my time maybe yours let's
find out together no but what's your
time John Humphrey is John the John
Justice John we've said your name on the
channel my last name to leave something
before no we haven't
gave me credit in Star Trek video no you
didn't because I remember that project
someone can we just use your left no
fine John Humphrey yeah yeah he doesn't
like using it well you know I like to
have my own my own life well not me no
for now me and some parts really I don't
have a Facebook fan page I just have a
Facebook page
who cuz they all know there you go
probably won't accept a request healthy
criteria there is I told people that my
name is Greg that's why just thinking
through it well you should have thought
that through before I announced it in
this video follow us on our social
networks yeah Reece Jerry's is Jerry
bloom house.com
yeah there you go there you go
interesting stuff right thank yes yeah
something like that all right you cut
the camera guy up again
check this guy out of the Greg Alba I
met the real rejects and can't real real
rejects out ok ok horn huh